the very existence of our union is been
questioned yet our citizens and the
world need a strong European Union like
never before
our wider region has become more
unstable and more unsecure the crisis
within and beyond our borders are
affecting directly our citizens slice
this is no time for uncertainty our
union needs a strategy we need a shared
vision and common action and this is
even more of true and important after
the British referendum only together we
can respond to the threats and seize the
opportunities the word offers to us
none of our countries alone can do so
but as a union of almost half a billion
citizens our potential is impressive
we are in the top three of world
economies we are the first trading
partner donor and investor globally but
we should also realize that we are not
making full use of our potential yet a
vast majority of our citizens understand
that we need to collectively take
responsibility for our role in the world
and wherever I travel our partners
expect the European Union to play a
major role including as a global
security provider we will deliver on our
citizens needs and make our partnerships
work only if we act together united this
is exactly the aim of the global
strategy for European foreign and
security policy global is not just
intended in a geographical sense it also
refers to the wide array of policies and
instruments the European Union has and
can use the strategy focuses on defense
capabilities and anti-terrorism as much
as on job opportunities inclusive
societies and human rights
it is about soft power because we are
the best at it but in today's words soft
power and hard power have to go and in
ends so the strategy sets out the
ambition of strategic autonomy for our
union but we can only be strong if our
friends
and partners are also strong my neighbor
strength is my own strength and we're
finally starting to understand this so
we will engage in a practical and
principled way sharing global
responsibilities with our partners and
contributing to their strengths we have
learned the lesson my neighbors and my
partner's weaknesses are my own
weaknesses so we will invest in win-win
solutions and move beyond the illusion
that international politics can be a
zero-sum game all of this will make each
of our Member States and each citizen of
our union better off because first and
foremost this is a strategy for our
citizens to serve our national interests
and our citizens aspirations we need a
strong a united European Union I know
well the joining all our cultures
together to achieve our shared goals and
serve our common interests is a daily
challenge but it is also our greatest
strengths diversity is what makes us
strong yes
our interests are indeed common European
interests and the only way to serve them
is by common means this is why we have a
collective responsibility to make our
union a stronger Union and this is a
collective responsibility for us for the
European institutions but also for each
of our countries and for all the people
of Europe so this global strategy will
now guide us in our daily work towards a
union that truly meets its citizens
needs hopes and aspirations a union that
builds on the success of 70 years of
peace a union with the strength to
contribute to peace and security in our
region and in the whole world